sardinha pensez quoi de la caricature
qui font de vous les guignols qu'est ce
que j'en pense bah quand c'est une drôle
c'est drôle invite à côté on a dans le
93 le sport national c'est quand même la
chambre est donc donc je n'ai pas de
problème à ce qu'on rigole de moi quoi
tant que c'est bien fait quoi là
biagioni tard tout le monde vous connaît
mais on vous connaît peu on va parler de
vous et de votre vie
alors votre vrai nom c'est didier
morville vous êtes né donnait pas
l'adresse quand même un nom didier
morville
ouais c'est ça ah vous êtes né dans une
cité la seine-saint-denis volts il
derrière votre terre acide irascible
comme comme non hein mais confondre
ouais vous ai fait une chanson
d'ailleurs s'appelle laisse pas traîner
ton fils ouais pour lui parler ou enfin
j'ai une chanson parce que jamais je
fais ce que j'ai donc après après comme
je disais l'enfant mort pour lui parler
c'est un peu tard maintenant ouais votre
mère aussi vous l'avez retrouvé assez
tardivement
ouais mais sûrement aux quarts des voix
vous être regardée comme toujours moi ça
va on n'a pas de famille quand on vous
disait qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand
tu seras grand de répondre j'ai quoi je
répondrai pas
je n'ai pas vraiment d'idée donc alors
92 avait un choc ou des vingt ans vous
allez au trocadéro et vous découvrez
deux jeunes américains qui danse le
smurf au son d'un ghetto blaster ses
débuts du hip hop vous rencontrez kool
shen à ce moment là beaucoup de chaînes
en fait ils habitaient deux côtés de
lamu moi je faisais d'un côté du de
l'autre donc c'était déjà fait agresser
avant moi j'ai été comme tous les
banlieusards à l'époque remontaient sur
paris des ponts et pour aller voir ce
que font les autres
ouais mais quand vous danser tous les
deux dans le métro vous gagner du pognon
non ouais un petit peu des miettes au
bout d'une heure et demie c'est ça
marchait bien gagner de la tune dans
tous les deux dans le métro châtelet les
halles gens qui font la manche
ça marche bien ça ça je suis bien quoi
ouais vous gagnez plus que votre père
par exemple
non je faisais autre chose pour gagner
plus comment alors en 84 donc c'est la
fin de l'émission de sydney est en fait
le graphique ci remplace un peu le smurf
et la breakdance dans le mouvement hip
hop c'est ça ouais le graffiti c'est un
truc en fait l'ami de cushing est un
livre d'histoire géographie est une
petite photo comme ça dans mes troupes
un new yorkais un parti la demande quoi
ouais ouais on a commencé un pisser dans
les coins et puis après saint jean alors
les parce qu'il faut savoir c'est ken tm
c'était un groupe de tagguer en 86 avant
d'être un groupe ii
chanteur et puis un jour pour rencontrer
dix troisième année johnny go et ils
vous disent le taxer de la merde c'est
le rap pied au top vous affirmer enfin
ils essaient de nous expliquer pro fait
de la merde et qu'on ait des merdes
c'est plus comme ça et nous méprenons
pas pourquoi gros pour pas grand chose
aussi à l'époque bon sédition valoir
répondait on a été dans le premier texte
dans la cuisine de mon père et de leur
montrer que on peut le faire nous aussi
les grands être visitée ce moment-là
nous dans le rap on va tout déchirer
et ça a donné ça
c
rang que le boulet
non
dupont
varois
la mère patrie du pays
chaque année pour fêter ça
m
je
les dépôts et
mme amos
non
m
pour ne plus suivre les règles du jeu
mais terre
voilà joey starr alors est ce que c'est
vrai que votre maison de disques epic
vous a suggéré à un moment que ntm qui
veut dire nique ta mère
ça signifie le nord transmet le message
non jamais jamais moi je peux je peux
prétendre un truc c'est que je fais
partie je crois des rares groupes et du
seul groupe en france qu'à jamais
présenté une maquette avant de faire un
album quoi souple mtm ça vous plaît bien
à vous avez tout seul parce qu'elle est
quoi mais tout ça n'est pas mariée c'est
ça c'est un bon parti moi aussi
pensez quoi du rap français en général
jesta bagnara perhaps et comme tout
moins un mois ouais c'est pas important
pour nous parce qu'il a un côté
caustique nous on est des hooligans
derrière s'il fait bien ne prend des
pincettes parce que je peux tu éclaté
alors et ça c'est des mesures étant
propos parce que ça peut aller très vite
aller tout de suite la violence la
violence voilà c'est un tuba voilà ça
c'est l'exemple même mois alors je
trouve un peu trop virulent pour la télé
alors je dise c'est quoi tes sont par là
la question c'est le rap français c'est
vous allez dis akena temps ils pas les
toucher doc gynéco c'est du plastique
sans consistance
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas nié affirmant
on fait un peu du gangsta rap et que les
autres font du rap normal moi je suis
pas un instant mais gangsta rap ça veut
dire qu'on a un gangster lui attendre
bas un peu un peu d'accord s'il ya
marqué de gangsters à mon rap d'accord
mais dit
et puis
l'agar agar je crois que moi moi je suis
plus dans un patient doit me situer je
crois que j'ai plus dans une catégorie
ou constat d'où certaines l'urgence en
fait là qu'on développe mais mais en
aucun cas je cherche à me faire passer
pour un bandit où je pense que déjà déjà
c'est manquer de respect aux gens qui
font ça et qui sont sous le coup des
saisons comme on dit nécessité fait loi
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui font ça
et qu'ils n'ont pas le chois compagne
d'autre choix at on pas d'autres outils
non plus pour pouvoir s'en sortir
bon déjà et puis ces gens là moi je vais
vivre je sais ce que je fais ici donc
par rapport à ça j'ai aucun droit de me
réclamer gangster voanews quoi je fais
de la musique
donc j'ai cette chance là quoi il est
pas très très chaud sur la france vous
avez déclaré le fn est dissous mais les
racistes reste assez moi qui aime ça
ouais je sais pas si je parle comme ça
mais allons-y ses bas on est toujours
dire est qu on est toujours dans le même
pays de collabos ou s en sort si ces
drapeaux qu'une fois les américains
arrivés
d'ailleurs on ce moment là qu'a regarder
la tv c'est plein de jeux je t'ai lumine
jeudi en conclusion que la bataille
ensuite donc qui s'appelait quoi donc ça
veut dire qu'on est bien on rappelle que
la boue quoi puis moi je suis pas très
problème c'est que moi je viens des
femmes et par an vient des colonies moi
je suis me suis quand même et puis on
n'a pas oublié qu'on est venu nous
chercher et puis que la france est un
pays cosmopolite donc abandonné moi j'ai
34 ans je paie beaucoup d'impôts en fait
encore sentir que je suis pas forcément
à ma place il ya peut-être quelque chose
qui m'a pas quoi le fait que j'ai une
tête ramé ça joue quoi tient le sourire
aussi le message le sourire shine mais
quand je les vois je suis pas donc
est-ce que j'ai l'impression joey starr
que malgré votre succès vous avez du mal
à vous sortir de la banlieue votre
enfance vous dit le sac à dos de la
banlieue il reste accroché à toi mon
univers il est là quoi je pense que si
on sort de ça je ne sais pas si j'ai
encore des outils pour moi je suis je
pense que je suis là parce que j'ai une
raison d'être je désire pas j'ai un
média dans les mains de gens profitent
pour présenter comme je ne peux la main
la majorité silencieuse donc surtout ça
en fait on ne combat quoi ouais j'habite
encore là à côté parce que notre
ailleurs pour le moment quoi que je dise
en déniant tout quoi c'est mon essence
quoi et puis des fois
joey starr vous pétez un peu les plans
alors on va pas faire le listing de tous
vos ennuis avec la justice mais c'est
vrai que j'ai eu souvent l'occasion de
vous affronter à vos comptes en droit
d'ailleurs je vous affrontez une fois
non ouais mais fait peur j'arrive devant
chez j'arrive devant chez sony et puis
je sais plus qui avait une entrevue que
ce journal que je dirigeais à l'époque
sa vue puisqu'il y avait moi je sais ce
qu'il dirait moi j'étais avec avec mon
amie béatrice et puis des gens nous ont
sauté dessus et puis dans l'entrevue
j'ai vu ça un monde était drogué ou un
truc un autre super anneaux dans quoi il
carrément il y avait une page complète
sur nos pages complètes y avait deux
lignes devraient c'est à dire qu'on
était dans la rue bien triche et moi
c'est tout ce qui était vrai le reste
était bien garde de 50 revue c'était des
interviews donc c'est l'interview du mec
si les avions vers le oui mais je pense
que je pense que quand même c'est un mec
à qui vous aviez ouvert le crâne qui
disait six mois il m'a ouvert le crâne
ouais mais je pense que je pense que ce
ne l'est sur ie des choses il ya des
crânes intéressant à voir de ma carrière
je pense que je pense que même si
entrevue ce un journal de merde il faut
savoir une chose c'est que quand même
fait du pseudo journalisme mais si
j'avais vendu à 7 ans du journalisme
mais c'est pas pour donc ceux de
journalisme il ya journalisme ce qui
veut dire qu un minimum on se rencontre
et quand on se rencarde c'est juste je
n'ai pas savoir ce qu'il ya sur atv
comme cette journaliste pouvait le
savoir je pense et son pv a quand même
marqué qu'à trois personnes tous au
dessus je suis tout seul avec ma copine
maintenant si c'est moi après qui passe
pour l'agresseur c'est quand même assez
bizarre
donc le fait que vous ayez écrit ça et
je vous connaissais pas non plus
samedi matin je le trouve des rangements
de nous demander pendant je pas pendant
un quart d'heure en le suivant dans la
rue s'il connaissait ma ganache bosse
pour savoir de quoi il parlait si vous
connais fait en fait voilà et c'est ce
qui lui a fait peur ce jour là si je
m'étais écoutez je joue au football avec
lui je n'ai pas fait ce qu'il faut dire
la réalité c'est qu'un mec est passé en
bagnole qui a vu que j'allais me faire
assassiner sur place vous qui m'a
recueillie dans sa voiture j'ai mis deux
gros coups de pied dans la dans la
bagnole les portières étaient en creux
comme ça le mec s'est arrêté huit cents
mètres plus loin
j'ai dit je suis sorti des rails si vous
voulez que je vous rembourse pour la
portière m'a dit non c'est pas grave
l'assurance paiera si vous aviez mis
dans ma tête j'avais émis dans la
bagnole je serais mort oui et en plus
avoir un policier à qui voulait même pas
vous un policier l'a choqué sera bien là
pour pour finaliser ça je suis venu au
pied voilà c'est fini maintenant wayne
gerdes jusqu'avant oui et l'hôtesse de
l'air c'est elle qui vous avez agressé
aussi bah ouais mais bon comme je dis
toujours c'est sans obligation d'achat
on aurait cependant lieu puis ça change
rien faut juste savoir qu'à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui quand même il ya air
france qui nous demande car qui me
demande de l'argent par rapport à un
manque à gagner vu qu'elle a quand même
pour une gifle après six mois de congé
maladie price dans l'album donc subi un
manque à gagner de peser pendant un an
et demi de fer france qui me demande ça
y'a km à la sécurité sociale qui me
demandent aussi d'argent oui ça veut
dire que j'ai déjà ça m'a déjà coûté 200
mille balles entre 300000 bâle et l'as
hautmont de monde encore 300 et il
l'avait fait en première pour soi comme
en france mais il a maintenant jusqu'à
maintenant mais je leur ai dit raillé
pour ce prix là pour ce prix d'un café
les femmes c'est pas bien et vous aider
à mieux là de quoi vous aider à mieux
plus calme c'est parce que vous avez un
disque avant tout parce que vous êtes
fait soigner
cool non là c'est une grange est là
c'est parce pas bons sur six le redis
fogel c'est peut-être lui qui a
notamment fait gaffe quand même il est
amoureux peut-être un le d'amoureux one
façon chabot chômeurs ce que je fais je
suis amoureuse chose enfin en attaque
mais même pas s'annoncer
non c'est pas ça c'est que je pense que
je pense qu'un an avant
j'allais sur les plateaux télé j'étais
avec kool shen donc il y avait à côté 10
millions gay plus aujourd'hui et je me
retrouve tout seul donc quelque part
c'est à moi de le jeu de l'agencé ce
côté les lions ont pas plus mal parce
qu'on entend parler plus et puis c'est
vrai pas une brute épaisse un petit
coeur qui bat d'ailleurs les dents en or
et
alors joey starr était bien à chauffer
les tenues l'avis même des rails et joey
starr vous êtes un petit peu souvent
dans la quatrième dimension on va vous
faire une interview quatrième dimension